We're asked to simplify log base
5 of 25 to the x power over y.
So we can use some
logarithm properties.
And I do agree that this does
require some simplification
over here, that having
this right over here
inside of the logarithm is not
a pleasant thing to look at.
So the first thing that
we realize-- and this
is one of our
logarithm properties--
is logarithm for a given
base-- so let's say
that the base is
x-- of a/b, that
is equal to log base x of
a minus log base x of b.
And here we have
25 to the x over y.
So we can simplify.
So let me write this down.
I'll do this in blue.
Log base 5 of 25 to the x over
y using this property means
that it's the same thing
as log base 5 of 25
to the x power minus
log base 5 of y.
Now, this looks like we can do
a little bit of simplifying.
It seems like the relevant
logarithm property here
is if I have log base x of
a to the b power, that's
the same thing as
b times log base x
of a, that this
exponent over here
can be moved out front, which
is what we did it right over
there.
So this part right
over here can be
rewritten as x times the
logarithm base 5 of 25.
And then, of course, we
have minus log base 5 of y.
And this is useful
because log base 5 of 25
is actually fairly
easy to think about.
This part right
here is asking us,
what power do I have to
raise 5 to to get to 25?
So we have to raise 5 to the
second power to get to 25.
So this simplifies to 2.
So then we are left
with, this is equal to--
and I'll write it in front
of the x now-- 2 times
x minus log base 5 of y.
And we're done.